it's been a whirlwind few days for
bachelor standout Luke Pell the 31 year
old war veteran captured viewers hearts
on Jojo Fletcher's season of The
Bachelorette unless you are he was even
set to become the next Bachelor but
producers went with Nick vile in a
last-minute switch up Luke tells Us
Weekly that they were already well into
planning for his season of The Bachelor
he even had his bags packed and
everything quote we had planned for
intro filming and had a plan to have my
sister come on for a date and give
advice as part of the show I met with
the Wardrobe guys everything was moving
forward everyone on the production level
was expecting it to be me as well are
there discussions happening for you to
be the next Bachelor
is a possibility Luke's story echoes
what a source close to the show told et
on Wednesday the source added that in
recent years Bachelor producers have
made multiple people sign contracts
before choosing the show's lead Luke
says it was a huge surprise but he is
happy to get back to his life in
Nashville quote I want to head back into
taking control of my own destiny